ein weites land im westen brasiliens
jedes jahr zu einem großen teil
überschwemmt
eine ungezähmte natur die bedrohten
tieren schutz gibt
und die menschen an ihre eigene
geschichte erinnert der herrscher der
wildnis den die hirten am liebsten jagen
und einer der das verhalten des jaguars
erforscht um das zusammenleben
friedlicher zu gestalten eine frau die
sich den respekt in dieser rauen welt
zuerst erwerben musste zwei mädchen die
den abenteuerspielplatz ihrer kindheit
schon bald verlassen werden und die
schon jetzt üben für ihr nächstes leben
in der schweiz
und was machen wir denn da
ja
[Musik]
es ist mai das hochwasser welches das
tiefland des kanals jedes jahr
weitgehend überschwemmt hat sich
zurückgezogen
die farben der leitzins befindet sich
250 autokilometer und campo grande
entfernt der hauptstadt des
bundesstaates mato grosso do sul
zum ersten mal seit langem ist die
strecke wieder befahrbar
der weg in die abgeschiedenheit führt
dann 38 4 garten vorbei
auf seiner holprigen fahrt durch die
wildnis begegnet lukas leuzinger nur
wenigen menschen
sechs stunden dauert die reise und den
rand der zivilisation worauf der farm
der leugners 2500 rinder verstreut sind
versender barranco alter so heißt die
farm
sie ist auch ein tierparadies das
frische gras muntert die pferde auf
[Musik]
und lobt allerlei besucher aus dem nahen
wald eine horde von wildschweinen eine
gruppe von windows die größten vögel
amerikas beobachtet von einem paar wird
sind arras
das pantanal fünfmal so gross wie die
schweiz nicht mehr als 200.000 menschen
leben hier
[Musik]
am tag nach seiner ankunft der schlug
assinger zuerst an den fluss ganzen
spezieller flusswasser schon relativ
kleine fluss also für sie verhältnis
bedrohung wird 50 km und ist völlig
isoliert im fluss wo fast der anfang hat
weil er von seinem sohn und hunde
kilometer wieder versorgt werden wie ein
riesiges und hat eigentlich nur mir
wurde aber veraltet und produktion gar
nicht was man sonst die arztserien zum
genannte und gehilfe flavio begleiten
ihn
lukas laut singer ist in brasilien
aufgewachsen in der schweiz studierte er
biologie jetzt sucht er zusammen mit dem
tierarzt nach frischen spuren des
jaguars sie wollen möglichst bald eine
der großkatzen einfangen und mit einem
senderhalsband ausrichten also got home
wird die von katarina witt und das ist
meistens wo andere tier bietet hier live
darum sucht man so wildwechsel vor wo
denn der jaguar hinter norbert also
paradies cup gewann das papier und die
st
jaguare bewegen sich gerne am flussufer
und hier filmte lukas 1 130 kilo
schweres tier so entspannt und
selbstsicher dass es sich schon keine
menschen stören ließ das ist es
bekanntlich sie es sehr wenig sexy und
dann passiert einfach nehmen am
flussufer verfolgung mitlaufen und so
haben sie und römische leider auf dem
verwilderten es ist die primitiv angst
die urangst vor schlange zum beispiel
und da wird einfach alle schlangen tötet
werde und alle großkatzen tötet werden
und sich als erster moderner gedanke
dass du ja muss nicht unbedingt tötet
werden auch die beiden schwestern lieben
ihren fluss letizia und enya sind auf
der farm aufgewachsen und erst als
letizia die älteren war sind sie wegen
der schule in die stadt gezogen
jetzt kommen sie noch am wochenende und
in den ferien hinaus auf die farm und
suchen ihre lieblingsplätze auf ein
strand der mit vielen erinnerungen
verbunden ist
hier zwischen alligatoren und piranhas
lernten sie schwimmen und hier hörten
sie zum ersten mal den jago april keine
angst vor all den wilden tieren
jetzt sind auch noch die eltern und
freunde nachgekommen
lukas schott lediglich einen piranha aus
dem fluss den emilia zuerst studiert und
dann freundlich weiterreicht marina ist
die urenkelin einer familie schweizer
die anfangs des letzten jahrhunderts
nach brasilien ausgewandert war
sie ging zurück in die schweiz um
agronomie zu studieren und an der eth in
zürich lernte sie lukas kennen
marinas vater hatte die farm in den 70er
jahren gekauft marina und lukas
beteiligen weiterhin rinder zu
doch gleichzeitig bemühen sie sich die
gefährdete natur des pantanal zu
schützen
ein tag auf der versender barranco geht
zu ende
die reihe versammeln sich auf bäumen die
so kurz nach den überschwemmungen noch
immer im wasser stehen und so schutz vor
räubern bieten die stiere haben die
nacht wie immer draußen verbracht
die extensive rinder wirtschaft im
pantanal kennt keine stelle und keine
most auf den weiten weiden verliert der
züchter jährlich viele tiere doch die
durch kratzer jaguar dem pommersfelden
zwischen schiavo sich also gerne prozent
bis maximal knapp zwei prozent die der
schlimm steht kopf
durch unsere majdic und die andere sache
also schlechtes management und so tief
in höhe
insgesamt fünf cowboys sind für das vieh
verantwortlich sie alle leben mit ihren
familien auf der farm exxon ist
vorarbeiter und chef der hüter der
auftrag heute eine herde von 500
muttertieren auf eine neue weise zu
bringen
[Musik]
ein guter vorarbeit und verband das ist
sein job ihren beruf basta sind so wie
sie nicht erkennt jede spur
krampe das obwohl er wisse schon zwei
hörner hat und praktisch gesehen
ganz unabhängig von der nummer wo sie
hat das gefühl das ist das leben
[Musik]
auf ihrer farm haben die leute immer
sein gästehaus eingerichtet der öko
tourismus hilft den betrieb
wirtschaftlich aufrechtzuerhalten weil
man bei abgekühlten wetter wenig tiere
sieht führt marina schweizer leuzinger
drei besucher auf eine tour zurück in
die familiengeschichte
davon ist ungefähr so groß wird die
zürich ganz thüringen bis zur etwas wie
der fall ist
so dass du jedes jahr finden können wir
noch irgendwo in mexiko
das ist wahnsinnig weil du hast richtig
war und dann mit google adwords schon
zeiten da hat ja da bin ich noch gar
nicht weiß wann die 400 seen befinden
sich auf dem gebiet ihrer form
das ist im prinzip wie überhaupt der
mensch dahinter ist weil der see her
schon sich füllt die drei bezieht und
woche zieht gott wasserdruck und lord in
der lade dir die kleine grüne gras ein
ausflug zurück in die kindheit dorthin
wo marinas vater seine erste hütte
erstellte im land des jaguars
niemand käme das sexy und einfach auf
diese fischart und beobachtet und er hat
mir im und die chance haben können
mitmachen
der schlechte geschmack zum zuvor
schicke weg marina lernte ebenso dass
dieses wilde land nicht nur eine große
magie verströmt sondern dass hier auch
schreckliche dinge geschehen können
[Musik]
die warum wurde während der abwesenheit
der familie schweizer von einem
einheimischen gehütet einem herrn
paulista
und der bekam streit mit seinem neuen
gehilfen und hat ihn umgebracht
dann hat mir dann aber müsse aber da wo
der ball ist das nicht
der band andi wenzel sowie es regnet
intensive wochen intensiven dann ist es
auch kalt extrem heiß und die ganz
intensität ist mit 100 und gott was hat
dich das mit dem brot
die einsamkeit des kantons produziert
viele legenden und geschichten und die
meisten drehen sich um den jaguar das
große kino der viehzüchter sonntags ging
sie auf die jagd und den rest der woche
schmückten sie die geschichte aus
marinas großmutter drehte diesen
stummfilm
wer der wut der katze mit einer bloßen
lanze widerstand dem war ewiger oben
gewiss die versender zu der die form der
leitzins einmal gehörte war halb so groß
wie die schweiz und beschäftigte ihre
eigenen jäger in den 70er jahren wurde
die jagd in brasilien weitgehend
verboten doch gewildert wird trotzdem
fasziniert von der kraft und der
vielseitigkeit der katze die er immer
wieder fotografiert chef lukas länger
sein eigenes schutzprojekt mit einem
team stellte er fotofallen auf in den
letzten acht jahren starteten sie sechs
tiere mit halsbändern aus die
funksignale aussenden
zwei von den tieren wurden von wilderern
getötet
und von diesen weibchen dass sie carol
nennen und das trächtig ist haben sie
seit vier tagen kein signal mehr arten
und es ist uns sehr unzugänglich
also machen
draußen und flugzeug ist eine antenne
befestigt tierarzt horcht auf
lebenszeichen aus dem halsband des
verschollenen tieres die suche nach
einem signal der verschollenen katze
blieb erfolglos
dafür finden letizia und emilia alles
wieder was sie in der stadt vermissten
[Musik]
das frühjahr hat der winter
wenn sie zusammen sind reden letizia und
emmi her portugiesisch zu hause mit
ihren eltern müssen sie schweizerdeutsch
sprechen
ein schapiro pärchen nistet auf dem
stinkt baum
und weil dessen samen von den hier sind
aras bevorzugt werden erhalten die
riesen störche auf den abend hin laut
starken besuch 14 taras die größte
papageienart sind bedrohte tiere hier
sind ganze bäume voller von zu finden
und vor allem zu hören
morgens um 6 uhr sind die cowboys
bereits auf den beinen
im choral sucht sich jeder sein
lieblingspferd
[Musik]
es fehlt frisches fleisch in der
vorratskammer der versender eine
routinearbeit für vorarbeiten und seine
leute
[Musik]
er zum sucht sein opfer nicht zufällig
aus er zielt auf eine kuh wie immer
wieder über die zäune setzt und dem
damit nichts als ärger bereitet hat
[Musik]
lange
der mensch ist hungrig und nimmt sich
ein recht
[Musik]
daher
und auch die anteilnahme der
schweizerischen braunen kann daran
nichts ändern
in minutenschnelle und mit geübten
schnitten wird das tier zerlegt das fell
soll möglichst unbeschädigt vom körper
getrennt werden
wie immer hat er zu seinem revolver
dabei im wilden westen brasiliens gehört
die waffe zur ausrüstung der cowboys
aber pumas und jaguare die sich ein tier
aus seiner herde und darf er hier nicht
mehr schießen
ich bin hier auf einer nachbarsfrau
warten
da hatten wir hunde und das war unser
spaß mit ihnen denn jaguar zu jagen
und wie ging die jagd mit der pistole
der jaguar flohe offenbar und peng
als letztes wird das fell aufgeladen aus
dem die cowboys später gurte und las aus
fertigen auf der fazenda barranco alto
werden jaguare zu wissenschaftlichen
zwecken gefangen und tierarzt reagieren
zum ist der spezialist in der kunst der
großkatze eine falle zu stellen
im dichten busch in jaguare viel
schwieriger zu erforschen als andere
raubkatzen die in der städte legen
deshalb werden jaguare eingefangen und
mit einem sender ausgerüstet
wir müssen mehr wissen über alle aspekte
die ökologie die größe des territoriums
wie lange leben sie wie verhalten sie
sich untereinander wie pflanzen sie sich
weiter darüber wissen wir fast nichts
wie lange bleiben die jungen bei der
mutter wohin gehen sie nachher das sind
viele fragen die wir beantworten müssen
tut nicht weh und dann wenn dann springt
zweck und die stark fangen jetzt ist die
große kunst mache dass der jaguar die so
ein riesiger gebiert denn davor dem fall
da um die 15.000 hektar das sind etwa
150 quadratmeter dass er genau das
innenstadt also sagen wir im fußball
große fläche jetzt muss die teenie star
macht mit zweigen wird der wildwechsel
zu einem schmalen pfad verengt zu
erhalten das sind aber dir was mir
kann's halt sind also das ist damit der
jaguar nicht irgend wird läuft sondern
jetzt damit in forcieren letzten
anderthalb meter dass er ein genaues
schritt macht und am schluss steht jener
stadt die raffinierte falle soll am
schluss wieder zu einem stück natur
werden angelockt wird der jaguar mit
hilfe eines lautsprechers wenn das
männchen dass dieses revier markiert hat
den ruf eines anderen mädchens wird dann
kommt es um zu kämpfen und auf diese
weise gramm test in die falle
[Musik]
sobald ein tier hinter schlinge gefangen
ist schlägt im haus von lukas länger ein
bewegungsmelder alarm nur ganz selten
greift der jaguar den menschen an
respektiert und wendet möglichkeit die
letzte minute der schuss oder so das ist
wenn man denn der bedeutung schuss ganz
ist die krise die kritische distanz ab
erst als profi aufregung im jaguar land
in unregelmäßigen abständen lockt der
ruf des männchens potenzielle
widersacher in den eher der falle
letizia und emilia entspannen sich bei
einem spaziergang am fluss
das felder geschlachteten kuh wird vom
hungrigen bayern gereinigt
in den häusern der angestellten finden
andre teile der crew ihren zuspruch
ein tag im pantanal geht zu ende aber
etwas ist im busch und jana sussmann
hans christen zwischen triumphierte ist
es wahrscheinlich dass man erst wenn man
große titel
jetzt.de sitzberechnung schlafmittel und
denn der mensch müsse so das ist der der
tat wenn wir jetzt müsse und dass gott
es ist fleisch und dann hat das
betäubungsmittel
dahinter heizen sprengkapsel impact of
steel sprangen platte und dann ist es
das betäubungsmittel fan auf einmal auf
und dann ist natürlich auch vater so der
sohn kopf schaden anrichten und jemand
relativ nicht reiner gott zum beschluss
gehen
der erste versuch misslingt die
sprengkapsel hat sich nicht entladen
der zweite schuss sitzt aber jetzt ist
es besser die wirkung abzuwarten machte
marcus hock dass imbisse und und shuttle
bäckerei nach ruhe
doch bevor die dann aber scheint die
gefahr gebannt
und die arbeit kann beginnen
ein menschen ist in die falle geraten
102 kilo schwer
lukas probiert ein senderhalsband an es
wird jede stunde den standort melden und
damit rückschlüsse über das territoriale
verhalten und die fressgewohnheiten des
tiers erlauben wenn wir das theaterstück
dennoch 56 verfügt das land mit dem
wasser sondern und kate bis zur
schwanzspitze miss die katze zwei meter
und sie erfreut sich bester gesundheit
mit reißzähnen die über vier zentimeter
lang sind
selten sind letizia und emilia so gerne
so früh aufgestanden
jetzt wird emilia nicht nur das eigene
herz schlagen
am liebsten würde ich ihn nach hause
nehmen konnten
ein auf weg mittel wird der raubkatze
eine lange benommenheit ersparen
damit wird der jaguar wieder seiner
natur überlassen
[Musik]
und dann sind drei monate vergangen im
pantanal ist der frühling ausgebrochen
[Musik]
bei den opfern gibt es nachwuchs
die ameisenbären mutter trägt die jungs
auf dem rücken durch den frühling
[Musik]
was ist aus dem jaguar geworden der mit
einem senderhalsband ausgestattet wurde
erst zu hause bemerkte lukas länger dass
er das tier bereits konnte also dass man
damals gefangen hat ist sie nicht auf
bessere bilder deines vorher schussbahn
begegnet sind dass ich der mannschaft
britta und margarete heißt schwarze
fleck und zwar weil das ist einfach der
mini lag aber für mich ist das wo
hervorstehen und in der name hat zwar zu
tage dass menschen wurde sogar früher
schon mal gefilmt man schwierigen
lichtverhältnissen mancher politiker
verwickelt in den revierkampf mit einem
stärkeren männchen und so etwas nur ganz
interessant frühwerke waren ganze
verhalten wiener unterwürfig sie am
anderen ende dann so sehr gut stellt
hatte kampf schnitt das miteinander
besser sondern ausgeben kommt und kurze
konflikt und da wird schnell entschieden
ich bestehe und wenn du es akzeptiert
mit mich alles in ordnung und sie mal
auf gebetet aber wieder weit dass inter
halsband dass mancher breiter angelegt
wurde hat bereits nützliche
informationen geliefert
wenn die akw bis christa hat dann blieb
danach also bis zu 45 tage an einer
stelle und das geht ja häufig verpönt
und denke mir war sehr großer hat das
ist eine information wo man vorher ohne
halsband die informationen verrieten
auch drei rinder hatte mancher britta
beim nachbarn gerissen
diese verluste wurden von leuten als
jaguar schutzprojekt dem farmer vergütet
ein großer vorteil ist dass mir der
druck wegnehmen
die gressenich ruhe hoffen ab und
zweitens heime guter vorsatz also man
hat zugang um island sco aufs land
gefordert und noch mehr informationen
findet zum beispiel was es so strässer
hat und wo sie sich aufhalten und so
[Musik]
das pantanal ist seit jahrhunderten ein
männer land wo alte patriarchalische
traditionen weiterleben
[Musik]
in dieses land hat sich marina verliebt
seit sie als kind hier ferien machte
das hat mich wahnsinnig prägte blick und
lernen und lernen lassen was landschaft
dir verzählt
nicht nur die landschaft ist extrem und
will auch die umgangsformen sind raus
haben sich gern und rechts recht finden
weil da wird so axel reich gruppe marina
bringt frische früchte zur schule
zusammen mit anderen fahrern aus der
umgebung finanzieren die leute lasst
diese schule für die kinder der bewohner
des pantanal ohne schule blieben frauen
und kinder in der stadt und es herrschte
eine ausschließliche männergesellschaft
die schule funktioniert als wochen
internat lehrer schüler ist anfangs
schuljahr mit dem motorrad alle farben
in der umgebung abgefahren um die eltern
aufzufordern ihre kinder in die schule
zu schicken
[Musik]
für marina selber war die schule ein
wichtiger ort um ihre persönlichkeit
auszubilden
als sie 15 war schickten ihre eltern sie
in die schweiz
auch marin us-töchter emilia und letizia
gingen im pantanal zur schule auch auf
sie warten nun die große veränderung
denn wald wollen die leute dass das
pantanal für einige jahre verlassen und
in die schweiz ziehen wo die töchter
einer familientradition gemäss ihre
schulbildung fortsetzen sollen
ja ich meine ist klar wenn wir dafür
können wenn ich nur dran sein könnte
dann wird man halt schlecht weil es ist
einmalig so vermutet daher und sie sind
extrem verwurzelt und es war ziemlich
glaub ich das ganze tour also
gefühlsmäßig will dass ich das ist
dachte natürlich so stark auf einem
wirkt so stark dass es sei richtig
[Musik]
und wieder sind ein paar monate
vergangen
es ist ende november der brasilianische
sommer hat begonnen
[Musik]
am ufer des rio negro sind
wasserschweine mit frischlingen
unterwegs erst ein paar tage alt da
braucht es schon eine mutige tante die
den wegelagerer beine macht
[Musik]
mit dem sommer kommt auch die regenzeit
bald wird das wasser aus der hochebene
in den kessel des pantanal fließen und
wieder einen großen teil des landes
überschwemmen die touristen sind bereits
weg jetzt bereiten sich auch die
bewohner der versender barranco alto auf
den abschied vor nur einige cowboys
werden auf der farm bleiben und die
trainieren heftig für das traditionelle
reiterfest zum abschluss des jahres die
mannschaften der nachbar farmen werden
erwartet und da möchte sich niemand eine
blöße geben
marina hat das fest vor jahren gegründet
um freundschaften zu bestärken die mit
den nachbarn aber auch die mit den
pferden den wichtigsten helfern der
panther neros marina brauchte jedoch
viel hartnäckigkeit bis sie sich in
dieser männerwelt durchsetzen konnte im
prinzip damit geboren und dann kommt
schon einer größe die erste reaktion ist
die und mitte zieht löst das müssen wir
weiter und so aber du darfst nicht in
zweifel stellen
ich muss alle löcher verständlicher
werden dass sie gestolpert und so weiter
das sind vorüber und folglich hier
machen ausstellung und schon rennt
standorte davon
auch für lukas leuzinger den
tierschützer und pharma naht die stunde
des abschieds und ich hoffe das ist aber
was mir da jetzt die letzten 15 jahre
gemacht hat dass das alles sowieso maxi
sind und dass das jetzt wieder wachst
der sender von mama britta dem jaguar
den lukas länger vor einem halben jahr
fing hat aufgehört die positionen
durchzugeben
foto fallen und es gerade blendend
schönes kräftig guten weg sind immer nur
das gleiche territorium oberlauf das
heißt der geschnittenes anders verdrängt
wurde
gibt es keine neuen spuren hat man in
der schweiz haben sich sogar für dieses
projekt sei illegal mit univer mit
schweizer universitäten zusammen pflicht
und auch interessieren damit machen es
gedauert die schweiz geht konflikt
zwischen fünf und schafzüchter das
jaguar projekt wird laut singer also
auch von der schweiz aus weiter mit
betreuen
zum richtfest kommt wie jedes jahr auch
die verwandtschaft zu besuch
verwandte sollen die farm weiterführen
während die 19 es in der schweiz leben
für marinas eltern jörg und evelyn
schweizer war das stück land im pantanal
ursprünglich jagdrevier und feriensitz
hier setzte sich jörg für den schutz der
fast ausgestorbenen riesenotter nein
er dokumentierte ihr jagdverhalten
bekämpfte die wilderer jörg schweizer
trug viel dazu bei dass die tiere in die
flüsse des pantanal zurückkehrten
jetzt spürt er sie nochmals die gute
alte zeit
und fast hebt er ab auf der einzigen
flugpiste wie früher als er hier jeweils
ein flugzeug unter dem hintern hatte
bei der ehemaligen jagdhund beobachtung
schütte werden schnell erinnerungen wach
[Musik]
netka kurs je geworden wie kann worte
sasha 7
denn ist mit einer jacke mit 105 huber
und jaguar und dann nicht faszination
von hamburg via will distanz und so eine
tobin erste chance mit mühe oder tiny
und bewegte und so also faszination für
der pantanal ist wirklich familie aber
auch die faszination für die alte heimat
ging in seiner familie nie verloren
der großvater wandert der kinder pro und
der sind eigentlich die schweiz
geschickt worden schon mein vater der
maler kleid du hast nur du bist vom
hopfen will ich zur brille durch chara
vor der nada was da gibt vom klima der
berne heißt die und ich bin im wald
cockpit und hat ihr beobachtet oder
klagte und wir wachsen und dass obama
offen kopf krankheit oder tod der
kadettin
seit fast 100 jahren bemüht sich diese
familie die schweizer kultur zu bewahren
und so werden die leute ja schon bald
den zauber der wildnis gegen die
annehmlichkeiten der schweizer
zivilisation tauschen
aber dieser wildnis ist gefährdet
[Musik]
immer mehr natürliche landschaft
verschwindet der busch wort wird zu
holzkohle das pantanal zur viehweide
diese entwicklung macht marina sorgen
mit anderen naturschützern setzt sich
marina dafür ein dass die landbesitzer
höchstens noch 50 prozent oder wie am
amazonas nur 20 prozent ihres besitzers
roten dürfen
der flug ruft aber auch den baldigen
abschied in erinnerung
[Musik]
ich bin ich glücklich ist wenn es mir
meist tiefer denn wenn ich bin ich froh
dass gesehen danach denn dann muss man
sich gedanken alle kunden prozent aber
dann fängt das reicht fest an
[Musik]
die große zeit für spiel und spaß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die musik spielt auf zum tanz um die
stühle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem pott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und es kommt zum schwestern duell
zwischen letizia und emilia schon und
seine männer haben dafür gesorgt dass
der grill gut bestückt ist
[Musik]
zum reit fest ist auch annina gekommen
die cousine aus der schweiz was macht
eigentlich ja aber wenn er dann bete
sind an das gefühl ich könnte heute
findet das er
bei der preisverleihung geht auch
vorarbeit zum nicht leer aus zwei
grundstücke ebenso für die gastgeber
denen ein schönes letztes wright fest
geglückt ist
der abschied ist herzlich aber kurz und
ohne große umstände ganz dem wesen der
pantanal los ging es
und wer ohne gold geblieben ist dem
bleibt immerhin ein stück vom grill wo
besser als in der epischen landschaft
des pantanal wüsste man dass große
veränderungen nur den boden schaffen für
neues leben und neue erfahrungen
[Musik]